joining me now are Dr Rachel Clark a
palliative care doctor and Dr Henry
Marsh who is a neurosurgeon and they
were in Kiev when the city was targeted
by Russian missiles on Monday welcome to
you both thank you very much Rachel
first of all
um I mean the bombardment early on
Monday as you were arriving by train
terrifying for you I'm sure but of
course for so many people across Ukraine
absolutely I mean Henry and I came out
to Ukraine last week to try and help
palliative care skills especially are
incredibly useful with the entire
country being subjected to these
horrific acts of Civilian Terror on
Putin's part and we came out of the
train station and literally were herded
underground by men with guns in uniforms
and spent a good hour pretty much
cowering underneath the station with
several hundred ukrainians there where
children men women elderly people and it
was absolutely terrifying we could hear
the explosions some that one of them was
so close you could actually feel the
impact in your chest and of course when
we finally got out from that underpass
we discovered that civilians had been
killed and these strikes were not
military or strategic at all the targets
were residential areas a children's
playground was targeted a young doctor a
children's cancer doctor was killed
while we were there in the underpass and
it was unspeakable yeah I read about it
it's truly awful Dr Marsh
you've had a long association with
Ukraine do you think that attacks like
this on civilian infrastructure hardens
attitudes in Ukraine that make people
more determined to see this through
I mean it's a history of bombing Germany
didn't defeat Britain with the blitz
Britain and America didn't really defeat
Germany by raising all their cities to
the ground this is simply terrorism
it'll achieve nothing anyway the
ukrainians are literally fighting for
their lives and their country they have
no option all my friends say well it
makes no difference we go carry on it is
a complete nonsense the whole thing it's
cruel it's barbaric and Frank to evil
yeah let's talk a little bit about why
you were there Dr Clark you specialize
in palliative care as I was saying how
are you seeking to help people in
Ukraine
well there's an enormous need at the
moment for for obvious reasons for good
end of life care but even before the War
Began eight months ago there was there's
precious little in the way of any kind
of palliative care infrastructure so I
came out with Henry at the invitation of
of some local political Care Specialists
to try and teach and train and support
doctors and also medical students in
delivering this desperately needed care
and one of the things that's happening
since the conflict began is hospices and
there are only 10 State hospices across
the whole of Ukraine not only are they
caring for the patients who are dying of
diseases like cancer but now casualties
from the front lines in the East are
being shipped over to hospices so now
they're looking after patients for
instance who maybe are a young soldier
who has been bombed maybe half their
brain has been being obliterated by one
of Putin's missiles and the people in
those hospices they're not used to
caring for trauma victims but they're
having to just roll up their sleeves and
do the best they can so any support that
we can provide and palliative care was
invented in the UK it's it the NHS is
the world leader in palliative medicine
it's an incredible opportunity to just
try and help practically and Dr Marsh I
was in Ukraine a few weeks ago and met
some British surgeons who were teaching
or helping to teach Ukrainian surgeons
particularly about trauma injuries
um give us a sense of the work that you
are able to do in terms of neurosurgery
well I'm I'm not a trauma surgeon and
neurosurgeon in fact is a very small
part of War Zone surgery because they've
been going to Ukraine for 30 years I
have dare I set quite a high public
profile there I have many friends and
colleagues and my role now is one I'm
supporting Rachel with this palliative
care program the other is simply to
raise the morale of my many Ukrainian
friends and say we love you we care for
you we haven't forgotten you and that's
very important for them and have most of
the
doctors stayed behind or have a have a
good number left the country now
no they haven't left they haven't left
no no no they're all I mean because
they've been at War since 2014 with
Russia in fact the Ukrainian military is
relatively well set up
um and there are enough soldiers there's
enough doctors as far as I can make out
but there are of course an awful lot of
casualties and the casualties provenger
is produced by modern Munitions a
grotesque quite grotesque and Rachel how
are the hospitals I mean obviously
you're dealing with hospices but how you
must hear about the hospitals and the
doctors and the surgeons how are they
coping at the moment
well there's this
experience that we've heard an awful lot
about
um you know that there's a Defiance and
an absolute
seething hatred of Putin that uh you
know we were told about every single day
everyone I met was was seething towards
this man who's inflicting such Horrors
on their country
but really they the the doctors are
nurses they've got their backs against
the wall they have no alternative but to
keep on going because the only
alternative is a dictator who wants to
obliterate their country destroy their
country and what struck me with all the
doctors I spoke to was how very close to
the surface profound trauma was
everybody knows somebody who has been
murdered everybody's involved with
caring for victims and I have no doubt
that there is a silent epidemic of PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder across
the country so doctors were gritting
their teeth doing what they can for each
other but my goodness the personal cost
for ukrainians is astonishing okay well
um Dr Clark Dr Marsh I appreciate you
both coming on the program thank you
very much indeed